oh hello there
I'm Abby sharp welcome to the special
edition of Abby's kitchen called toilet
talk where we answer all your burning
bowel movement questions let's get
started
today's question is your avid what the
[ __ ] are FODMAPs it should I stop eating
them
signed bod not flustered hey you thought
not flustered I can sympathize with your
name bon mots are quickly replacing blue
as the proposed possible trigger a
digestible and irritable bowel symptoms
vomit stands for preventable
oligosaccharides disaccharides
monosaccharides and poles yes it's a
long series of words and syllables that
correspond to an equally long list of
words include a wide range of foods
vegetables dairy breeds like you and
sneakers
paraquad Macedon apricots apples
blackberry kidney beans soy milk anyway
some experts believe the short-chain
carbohydrates aren't very well absorbed
by some people in your small intestine
so they move into the large intestine
with a draw in water and get fermented
by your gut bacteria this can lead to
gas cramping
diarrhea and constipation in other words
guys
if you feel like you may be experiencing
irritable bowel syndrome or just general
digestive distress be sure to speak to a
registered dietician about the
possibility of trying a low fodmap diet
hey I can't promise it's gonna be easy
but it may just help well thanks so much
for your question there fodmap plus
you're like cope by sort of that 104 you
if you have a burning bowel question be
sure to leave me a comment below and
I'll try to answer it in an upcoming
episode of toilet talk thanks so much
for watching guys be sure to subscribe
to my channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen
you